- All right.
(audience applauding)
It's almost that time, but before we go,
I have one more story to share.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(audience applauds)
(funky music)
A young couple has made it their mission
to visit every country in the world,
and they are well on their way.
This is so cool.
So far, they've traveled to 112 countries,
which leaves about 80 more
to go, which is incredible.
Along the way,
the couple is documenting
their experience online.
Let's get them in here right now.
What's up, Emily?
(audience applauds)
What's up, Hudson?
- Hi, Kelly!
Thank you so much
for having us.
- Oh my.
Wait, where are you?
- We're in Thailand right now.
This is one of our favorite countries.
The people and the food are incredible.
So we'll be here in
Asia for the next month,
and then we're headed to West Africa next.
- And how this whole
thing for travel started
is we met in fifth grade.
We started dating in high school.
- What?!
- But it was actually in college
when we came up with our initial goal
to buy this old RV
and set out to travel the 50 states.
But then, after we got
married, a few years later,
my dad just suddenly passed
away from a heart attack.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And that was just a reminder to us
that we're literally
not guaranteed tomorrow
and we wanna make the most of the time
that we have together.
So that next year, we sold everything,
bought this old RV and renovated it,
and started traveling to the 50 states.
But we just fell in love with travel
and now we're in our 112th country.
(audience cheers)
- That's in-
All of that that you
just said is incredible.
The fact that you've known each
other since the fifth grade.
I didn't know that part.
That's incredible.
(Hudson laughs)
Congratulations.
Still like living your lives together.
That's incredible.
- [Hudson] Thank you.
And also, like, just
such a cool, like, thing
and what a cool purpose to like,
go visit different cultures
and different places
and have these conversations
with different people.
This is an amazing thing.
So let's get some rapid
fire recommendations.
Like Emily, prettiest country so far.
- Egypt.
The pyramids were incredible.
- [Hudson] Argentina,
Patagonia is so beautiful.
- Oh my god.
I think I'm gonna have to
agree with Hudson on that one.
Okay.
Best-
(Hudson laughs)
That picture, geez.
Best food.
Where do you think, Hudson?
- Mexico for sure.
- [Emily] And for me, Thailand
where we are right now.
- Okay.
(Emily and Hudson laugh)
The friendliest people.
Where do you think?
- [Hudson] Middle Eastern hospitality
is definitely unmatched.
- We've been so inspired
by people's kindness
and hospitality all around the world,
but I'd have agree with the Middle East.
- Oh my God, that was-
I mean, you guys, your pictures.
I hope you make a book or something
and like, let everybody
(Emily and Hudson laugh)
join in on that by looking at it, it's so,
it's so incredible.
- Thank you so much.
- These pictures.
Congratulations on
everywhere you've been
(audience applauds)
and you're about to still go to.
That's the coolest thing ever.
You're like my favorite couple.
I'm liking your post-
- [Emily] Thank you so much.
- Right now.
(heart button chimes)
- We are so inspired by you,
Kelly, thank you so much for having us.
- Absolutely.
Well that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like y'all.
So they're gonna write y'all a check
for a thousand dollars to help y'all out.
(audience cheers)
- Oh my god, that's so nice.
- You're so kind.
- Thank you so much!
- Thank you guys so much.
Y'all have so much fun.
And thank you to all our guests today.
Cara Delevingne, Nicholas Sparks,
Jen Goodrich, Shandy Rice,
Dachiana, and JORDY.
Y'all have a great day and if it's not,
well try and change it.